all right let's talk about msnbc i know
nobody's really watching this channel
but i think it's important to highlight
the nonsense that the media
puts out there because that way when you
talk to your blue and on friends
who think that antifa is just an idea or
who think that the america
was about to be toppled on january 6 or
whatever
their conspiracy of the day is you you
are armed with some information you can
go oh but you know
the people that you watch are actually
crazy people or
even their own networks edit them
because of some of the nonsense
that they spout so anyway this is joy
reads
show and you're gonna see
the full thing here you're gonna see the
unedited clip that was played
live on msnbc talking about antifa
and then she offers up a very bizarre
conspiracy theory uh
and then we'll make note of of what
exactly they edited out when they
uploaded it
to the internet yeah and angela
completely anticipated my question that
i was going to have to you clint watson
i think we've set this up perfectly
because that's the question that i have
as well because before
any of this took place um if and let's
just listen to louis gomer and he if
he's claiming
that he was being told by capital police
officers that there was going to be this
influx of antifa
who they've claimed were basically the
devil they're just anti-fascists they
don't really
show up anywhere if we're seeing in some
of these cases um
where proud boys and and etc are saying
that they anticipated
that antifa would come and fight them
that black lives matter supporters would
come and fight them
so that donald trump could then impose
the insurrection act and they could act
as a militia we're seeing that in some
of the cases
okay so first off i want to read the
craziest part of the quote before i tell
you what msnbc cut there
antifa they're just anti-fascist they
don't really show up anywhere
lady you gotta screw loose okay that's
the nicest way i can put it because
they're burning
down portland and seattle and they've
destroyed
parts of los angeles and san francisco
and new york city is becoming dangerous
and many other blue cities but when the
president tells you that antifa is just
an idea and then this woman says they
don't really show up anywhere
because these people literally have blue
goggles over their eyes apparently well
gateway pundit
found out that msnbc didn't want
everybody
to hear joy's crazy conspiracy theory
this is direct from
the gateway pundit msnbc appears to have
stealthily
edited a crazy rant from joy reid in
which she spouted a bizarre conspiracy
theory and defended antifa
saying they don't really show up
anywhere the portion of the discussion
is mysteriously not
included in the segment that msnbc
uploaded online
but has been obtained by the gateway
pundit that's what we just showed you
the timestamp was also removed from the
bottom right corner of the screen
of their upload possibly to cover up the
edit it is present in the original clip
in the original version reed is
discussing her bizarre conspiracy theory
that
capital protesters believed they would
be fighting antifa and black lives
matter
so that president donald trump could
impose the insurrection act
and remain in office so the reason i
wanted to do this was a
just to shed more light on just the
inability
it's not even inability the the direct
and blatant
lies that these people say when they're
talking about antifa so it's not the
inability for them to cover antifa
properly
they actually obfuscate and purposely
don't want you to see
certain violence because they want you
to see other violence but then she went
on this crazy rant
this sort of made-up rant about that
they were gonna have to fight the proud
boys there and then trump would use the
internship
it's just all made up nonsense and we
know about all the nonsense that these
people make up constantly so it's like
if you got a cousin that's watching
msnbc
it's like that's like pretty much
dealing with someone in a mental
institution and i don't know what the
best way to do that is like do you need
to
you know meet them for coffee once a
week slightly drug the coffee and then
and then you can get them out over a
course of months don't
please don't quote me on that that's not
you shouldn't be drugging your blue and
on
cousin from the mental institution oh
there's the there's the clip for media
matters have at it guys
um anyway when i talk about lie
laundering this is exactly what lie
laundering is you get an msnbc host
telling you that what you can see
doesn't exist meaning antifa burning
things down
and then what didn't happen is really
the important thing meaning that
proud boys were going to show up and
that trump then would use the fighting
for the interruption act that's a thing
that
did not happen but that's what she's
really focused on as opposed to the
things
that do happen and even the executives
at bananas msnbc thought that was
too crazy to air which is why they cut
it
change the timestamp and everything else
which is just so consistent
which how which with which the uh
mainstream media and corporate press
works
you